première invitée du 7-8 ce soir
christophe hillairet bonsoir annonceurs
êtes le président de la chambre de
commerce interdépartementale
d'agriculture en ile-de-france pas de
commerces ou m'arrêter de la chance
voilà j'en aï vulture pardon
interdépartemental en ile-de-france lors
de son discours de politique générale à
l'assemblée mardi jean marc ayrault a
annoncé la création d'une loi cadre pour
une agriculture diversifiée et durable
et performante mais il faudra attendre
le second semestre 2013 pour en savoir
plus c'est la date de sa préparation
les agriculteurs en attendant quoi de
cette future loi cadre rien c'est à dire
que ça fait la dernière loi de
modernisation agricole date d'il ya un
an et demi et c'est à dire très très
compliqué en fait pour le monde agricole
de se positionner par rapport aux
volontés politiques puisque à chaque
changement de gouvernement on a une
nouvelle loi qui sort je voudrais
rappeler simplement que l'activité
agricole c'était un cycle long c'est à
dire qu'entre le moment où on sème une
graine et on la récolte c'est quand même
une année et quand on élève des animaux
ça peut être encore même plus long que
ça ça peut être trois ou quatre ans et
quand on a des politiques qui change en
fait absolument en permanence ça devient
très très compliqué en fait à se
positionner pour le monde agricole pour
vous ce changement de loi ne répond à
aucune logique c'est juste défaire ce
qui a été fait par le précédent
gouvernement moi je pense entre autres
sas et je pense qu'il ya ça et puis de
vouloir inscrire en fait une volonté à
un moment donné par rapport à une
activité qui est l'activité agricole
mais bon je veux dire on peut travailler
intelligemment sans forcément pour nous
cette loi et cette loi c'est se justifie
par le fait en tout cas du point de vue
du gouvernement qui lie à la pac la
politique agricole commune aussi qui va
être réformé en 2014 ça s'inscrit dans
une certaine une certaine logique selon
vous et puis ça dénonce justement la
logique de votre inverse c'est à dire
que la politique agricole commune
devrait l être
la ligne directrice qui permette
derrière de mettre en place des lois
dans les différents pays pour mettre en
application cette politique agricole
commune pac on espère encore commune de
votre côté avec la chambre
interdépartementale d'agriculture en ile
de france vous avez interpellé pendant
la campagne les candidats aux élections
législatives sur des points précis
notamment sur la peyrie la pérennisation
des activités à la périphérie des villes
en fait c'est la périurbanisation
qui vous inquiète c'est ça la difficulté
aujourd'hui bas par à composer avec les
villans fait braquer pas qui nous
inquiète c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une activité là qui développe et
de l'activité agricole en proche
périphérie des villes devient
extrêmement compliqué nos cernon bas
permanents avec les citadins alors les
citadins avec les collectivités avec les
aménageurs puisque en fait on voit
souvent malheureusement les terrains
agricoles qui sont notre premier outil
de travail uniquement comme un
consommable qui permet de faire du
développement soit en termes de logement
soit en terme économique y est
malheureusement peu pense que sur ces
terrains c'est pas uniquement de la
nature c'est aussi un moyen de faire
vivre des familles et puis faire est de
créer des emplois même en ile-de-france
l'absolu mais parce qu'on pense aux
territoires forcément un petit peu
éloigné mais à la périphérie de nos
villes de saint quentin du département
forcément on cultive on travaille
également 45 % du territoire il est
encore agricole en ile de france et
puisque vous donner un pourcentage bien
donner un autre 2 % en moins chaque
année de surfaces agricoles en ile de
france c'est ce que vous annoncez basse
est de mise et pince m et par an c'est
l'équivalent d'une commune qui disparaît
en permanence et à l'échelle française
ses 26 mètres carrés qui disparaissent
chaque seconde et c'est un département
tous les 7 ans c'est la même situation
dans tous les départements d'île de
france il ya des endroits où mal ccc
plus présent bien évidemment plus on
s'approche de l'agglomération parisienne
est par exemple le les hauts-de-seine il
y a plus d'agriculteurs maintenant
depuis dix ans dans les hauts de seine
c'est à directement des yvelines à côté
de ça dont les départements des yvelines
encore c'est encore à peu près
6 à 700 exploitations quoi faut-il
conserver des terres agricoles près des
villes c'est la question que nous sommes
allez vous poser aujourd'hui écoutés oui
bien sûr c'est important d'avoir des
tailles ricol ce serait bien qu'on
puisse assurer notre propre consommation
locale plutôt que de revenir d'espagne
ou n'importe où de très loin en tout cas
de polluer la planète plutôt que le
premier local mais bien sûr si c'est la
mort du paysan c'est la mort de la
france c'est clair je penserai parce que
bon ça permet aussi que tout ce qui est
produit localement au niveau tout ce qui
est transports
et tout le reste bon bah ça réduit
notamment les coûts de frais pour les
consommateurs voient l'arrivée
principalement ainsi que tous les
pollutions tout ça ça réussit
faut construire et à passer de logements
voilà faut construire beaucoup les gens
ils couchent et le parterre dehors ils
sont passés logement je sais bien
d'avoir la production pas très loin de
la consommation
et puis ça met un peu de réalité dans ce
monde y en a un peu besoin je pense que
le vie urbaine
parce que c'est qu'une vache et et à
l'open terre comme on élève des comment
comment on fait pousser des tomates des
carottes je pense pas que ce soit
dérangeant près des villes à partir du
moment où on n'utilise pas trop de
pesticides ya peu de raison que ce soit
dangereux pour olivier ah oui moi je
veux qu'on en garde près des lignes je
suis d'accord oui oui parce que comment
dire il faut que la nature entoure les
villes les villes sont tentaculaire rcd
sommes des hommes que la nature
disparaissent
mais plutôt content à l'écouté des
réponses globalement on va dire 99% des
gens que nous avons rencontrés soutien
dans l'agriculture ils veulent encore
des des terres agricoles aux portes de
leur ville mais ce qui est assez rigolo
dans les témoignages là qui sont
annoncés c'est que beaucoup fantasme
l'agriculture c'est à dire ont une
vision qui est pas forcément la vision
réelle de l'activité agricole au jour
d'aujourd'hui et c'est assez rigolo de
voir le décalage qui peut y avoir mais
par contre effectivement on a la même
ligne c'est à dire que pour nous pour
pouvoir produire nourrir et ça veut dire
qu'il faut un outil de travail et ça
peut pas des fraises hors sol ça marche
mais c'est bon voilà c'est un modèle qui
pas forcément souhaitable mais il ya un
conflit parce que forcément entre les
citadins et puis également les paysans
les exploitants agricoles on entendu
dans le micro trottoir les gens dorment
dehors il faut construire des logements
ya pas assez de logements c'est à dire
que nous on est un peu témoins
malheureusement d'un changement de la
société et notamment avec de plus en
plus de familles monoparentales et donc
houleuse à la télévision
on est absolument les victimes puisque
chacun veut avoir son logement etc et un
moment donné chacun veut avoir aussi son
locataire son bout de gazon etc or
malheureusement on n'est pas dans des
pays comme aux états unis où les espaces
sont à perte de vue on est un petit pays
et à chaque fois qu'on consomme pour un
bout de terrain pour une entreprise sur
lequel on va avoir besoin des espaces
verts autour etc
c'est du potentiel de production et de
nourriture qui disparaît content de ce
rapport entre la campagne et la ville
est justement les sites alors parfois
considèrent mal ou en tout cas ne font
pas attention c'est pas si c'est
volontaire ou pas mais vous êtes victime
aussi de dégradations au quotidien c'est
à dire que je viens dans les campagnes
quand on est citadin c'est un terrain de
jeu un petit peu l'attentât absolument
je pense que c'est dû notamment à une
éducation qui a disparu c'est à dire que
autant la génération aujourd'hui qui a
50 60 ans était beaucoup originaires du
monde agricole aujourd'hui on va passer
un cap on a une nouvelle génération et
qui ne sait plus ce que c'est que du blé
confondant du blé et de l'herbe confond
ne sait pas que par exemple pour avoir
du lait il faut qu'une vaches et un veau
etc des choses qui part est du b à ba
aujourd'hui mais qui aujourd'hui ne sont
plus des évidences pour bon nombre de 2
de la population et donc ce qui engendra
certaines fois un non respect de ces
territoires là c'est à dire qu'ils ont
l'impression d'être en pleine nature et
donc la nature appartient à tout le
monde alors que nous c'est notre
activité c'est notre portefeuille à un
moment donné est donc une moto ou un 4 4
qui va traverser un champ de blé c'est
autant de pertes veut en fait pour les
exploitants font qu'aujourd'hui vous
demandez quoi aussi au gouvernement au
delà de la loi dont vous ne voulez pas
un pour 2013 dont on parlait tout à
l'heure mais aujourd'hui les demandes
sont sur ces points précis là notamment
alors des lois plus sévères par exemple
c'est pas forcément des lois plus
sévères mais c'est qu'à un moment donné
on a des territoires qui fonctionne de
façon complètement différente sur le
plan agricole que des territoires en
province est ce que l'on demande c'est
d'avoir une reconnaissance de ces
territoires comme la montagne à une
reconnaissance du handicap naturel nous
on handicap artificielle est ce qu'on
demande c'est une véritable politique ça
veut pas dire forcément de l'argent
public mais ça veut dire à maman de
déployer une véritable politique pour
pouvoir avoir une agriculture qui soit
performant qui réponde aux aspects
sociétal en région ile de france quand
on appuie l'abattoir on a pu les trie on
a pu de c'est à dire que tout
l'industrie de transformation alors
quand les consommateurs disent il faut
absolument en région parisienne que la
production puisse aller directement aux
consommateurs sauf que quand vous n'avez
pas d'abattoirs entre les deux comment
vous faites sauf que quand vous avez pu
de moulins entre les deux ou deux
laiteries vous n'êtes pas en capacité
d'avoir des filières courtes et
malheureusement en ile de france
aujourd'hui il y a plus d'abattoir il ya
plus de deux laiteries il ya de moins en
moins de meunier donc il ya un véritable
problème est ce qu'il faudrait aussi
plus de zones protégées de zone agricole
protégée pas forcément parce que moi
j'ai pas envie de finir dans une réserve
d'indiens c'est à dire que et d'avoir
des fermes type fermes de marie
antoinette qui soient des fermes modèles
mais qui n'ont pas de l'existence
proprement dits économiques alors chez
que marie antoinette est pas très loin
d'ici mais je sais pas si c'est
forcément un modèle agricole à vouloir
développer sur nos territoires nous ce
qu'on a envie c d exploitation qui soit
économiquement viables qui produisent
qui répondent aux aspects de la société
et puis aux enjeux de demain puisque je
rappelle que quand on veut être neuf
milliards de personnes sur la planète il
va falloir trouver des terres et on en a
pas partout sur la planète qui sont en
capacité de produire de l'alimentation
et aussi la certitude lorsque vous vous
lancez dans ses exploitations de pouvoir
les garder un certain nombre d'années
bien évidemment c'est ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui non c'est pas le cas et
je vais pas vous cacher qu'aujourd'hui
pour reprendre une exploitation agricole
c'est des capitaux qui sont absolument
énorme pour un revenu qui est souvent
relativement faible et donc qui est pas
fortes et pas forcément très sexy
aujourd'hui auprès des jeunes d'aller
s'installer en ce que quand ils en
veulent pour l'heure précise que du jour
au lendemain on va dire presque sont
caricaturés qu'on peut reprendre leurs
terres et souvent c'est souvent le cas
en ile de france et avec une pression
urbaine qui est de plus en plus
importante et qui met une incertitude
sur l'activité oui c'est donc ça
aujourd'hui votre priorité en
ile-de-france en tout cas - nationale
aussi mais pour pour la chambre au
niveau de l'île de france il ya une
autre information qui a été annoncé
cette semaine aux lois au delà de la loi
cadre dont on parlait il y a aussi le
revenu des agriculteurs
elle aurait promis lors ils auraient
progresser ses revenus en 2011 +3 8% en
un an revenu moyen annuel à 30 de 1500
euros pour un actif non salarié nous
l'avons pas si mal pour les agriculteurs
est-ce qu'on est le de france c'est le
cas aussi bas tout 32000 euros bon je
veux dire c'est un salaire tout ça à
progresser c'est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'au regard des 32000 euros les
les capitaux investis pour pouvoir
décrocher 32000 euros sont absolument
conséquent c'est à dire acheter des
terres ou louer des terres aujourd'hui
ça coûte excessivement cher et je vais
pas vous cacher que la grosse difficulté
c'est pas forcément le niveau de revenu
c'est la variabilité du revenu c'est à
dire que d'une année à l'autre puisque
aujourd'hui nos marchés sont mondiaux eh
bien on peut avoir le prix des denrées
qui flambent d'un seul coup qui s'écoule
le lendemain les marchés pétroliers qui
flambent et donc nos engrais qui vont
augmenter aussi fortement enfin voila
c'est c'est extrêmement compliqué
puisqu'on est complètement plongé sur
les marchés mondiaux et les récoltes de
cette année pour l'instant c'est moisson
n'a pas débuté sauf sur les escourgeons
donc les orges qui vont servir à la
bière entre autres mais la moisson
vacances va démarrer probablement
prochainement et à le s'annonce plutôt
pas mauvaise vue la pluviométrie qu on a
eu jusqu'à maintenant on espère en tout
cas qu'elles sont bonnes en fait ya une
progression fait du revenu sur un an
dont +3 8% mais c'est au niveau national
et de fortes disparités et là où c'est
le plus difficile c'est les grandes
cultures céréalières c'est finalement ce
qu'on retrouve en ile-de-france fait
absolument mais c'est c'est complètement
erratiques c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'on a une très
bonne année il ya deux ans il ya trois
ans c'était absolument catastrophique et
puis là cette année les prix ont
tendance à se tasser notamment à cause
des marchés pétroliers puisque le prix
de nos intrants coûte de plus en plus
cher de tous tendre d'ailleurs c'est à
dire que vous preniez les engrais ou
d'ailleurs la matière organique faire
venir des fumiers et c'est ça coûte très
très cher une dernière question l'a pas
précisé pour au cours de cet entretien
un exploit si une exploitation type en
ile de france ressemble à quoi mais y'a
pas d'exploitation type ya plusieurs
types d'exploitations en ile-de-france
mais effectivement la majorité des
exploitations et tourner autour d'eux
des céréales et pourquoi paris est à
paris un moment donné c'est parce que le
bassin de production et les terres
étaient très riches autour de paris ces
salles d'ailleurs qu'on construit
aujourd'hui mais paris est à paris parce
que tout autour de paris les terres
étaient excessivement fertile et elle
permettait d'alimenter très facilement
l'agglomération parisienne et c'est
celle qu'on est en train de détruire par
la consommation des espaces dans le sang
avec votre venue sur le plateau
organisée très structurée pour vous
faire entendre auprès des instances des
pouvoirs périgny nombreux alors il faut
être organisé si on veut se faire
entendre c'est à dire que quand vous
êtes plus que 2000 agriculteurs noyé
dans onze millions d'habitants soit vous
vous fourrez un gros mégaphone soit
avoir un des bons réseaux pour faire
entendre et ça peut aboutir par exemple
par exemple sur le cruiser le fameux
pesticides utilisés et qui est à
l'origine donc puisqu'il a été interdit
de ces deux des boues seulement des
abeilles les abeilles qui ont du mal
ensuite à retourner au bercail du coup
ça veut dire que c'est une bonne chose
de cruiser par exemple d'avoir fait une
bonne chose ou une mauvaise chose ce
qu'on a besoin nous dans le vent de la
victoire vous voyez ça comment ni une
victoire ni une défaite c'est qu'à un
moment donné moi j'ai besoin d'outils
qui me permettent de gérer mon
exploitation d'outils qui soit chimie
qui soit non chimiques qu'ils soient
agronomique mais il me faut des outils
c'est à dire que supprimer le creuset
ressent à voir d'un autre côté trouver
des techniques agronomiques qui nous
permettent d'endiguer un certain nombre
d' attaques parasitaires est un
véritable problème mais je ne suis pas
forcément favorable aux coureurs merci
christophe hillairet d'être venu sur ce
plateau président de la chambre
interdépartementale d'agriculture en
ile-de-france est la suite du 7-8 avec
elle la page échos et puis une séquence
décryptage sur le logement étudiant
juste après cette petite parenthèse vous
allez voir que du côté de magny les
hameaux on organise aussi des flash mobs
ils dansent sur le parvis de la mairie
de magny les hameaux une flash mob la
première du genre dans la commune
proposée par un animateur de la ville et
pour ce faire ces danseurs d'un jour ont
été avertis via les réseaux sociaux
ça s'organise justement sur youtube sur
internet où on fait passer les vidéos
fait passer les messages bien sûr et
après justement c'est de bouche à
oreille
doucement
dommage
non
il on s'est dit que c'était l'occasion
jamais avec un temps pareil de s'amuser
oui moi c'est elle qui m'a embarqué
qui m'a obligé c'est bien qu'ils fassent
à manille ça ça fait connaître deux
heures la ville et le principe super
bien quoi parce que je connaissais pas
ces damidot deby me dit flash moi que je
dis c'est quoi ça et il va expliquer le
principe et voilà c'est super sympa quoi
et non d'en faire plus ou d'hormones et
david du cbo prévoit une autre flash mob
ont l'année prochaine et emmène plus
large participation
ah ah